so as a christian talking to a fellow
christian um
i know multiple christians who are very
much in favor of the social justice view
of
gender and sex and whatnot um my
question is how do i interact with
someone like that who's not able to
to distance themselves from that in such
a way as to be able to say you know a
man is definitely a man a woman is
definitely a woman
when they claim to be a christian also
can you cancel me
you got to give me a reason to cancel
you uh my beard isn't as good as yours
well it's but you're wearing the mask so
i can't i can't show them
yeah i guess i could cancel you for
wearing the mask to begin with but
that's great i know i know you're all
were
you all were told to do that um okay so
the question was uh
as christians how do we engage with the
social justice stuff
with other christians who believe in the
social justice side of things
yeah i think
look i'm not always the best guy to ask
this because my i always err on the side
of
being straightforward and aggressive and
direct
um and maybe maybe that's not always the
answer in every situation
i have to admit but i think we're
getting to a point where we can't afford
to to approach it any other way you know
um
especially when there's so much noise
out there in the culture like at a
certain point you have to start yelling
to be heard
or over top it and so i i'm in favor as
christians
especially confronting other christians
who are misrepresenting our faith i mean
if somebody's out there
as a christian saying oh well the gospel
endorses the general mutilation of
children
or the murder of children in the womb um
i think a very
aggressive not to say physically
aggressive but very aggressive and
confrontational approaches
is correct and that's if you look in the
gospels
you know and that's people who who've
rarely read the gospel and most sjw
christians have not read it and you can
tell but um
when someone actually does sit down and
read it they're they might be a little
surprised when they realize wow you know
this jesus
this jesus guy was uh was pretty
confrontational
that's that's what he was doing through
his entire earthly ministry actually was
confronting
the evil and sin of his day and
especially religious
hypocrites and what is a religious
hypocrite a relationship is not simply
someone who says one thing and does
another original hypocrite is someone
who claims to believe something they
don't
and these sjw christians claim to
believe
in the christian faith and it's clear
that they don't really so they are
hypocrites and i think we should
approach them the same way that jesus
approached hypocrites